المترجم: fatima ma
المدقّق: Ghalia Turki
سأستمر بالمحاولة!
قرأت الشهر الماضي دراسة أجريت منذ فترة
تشير إلى أن 2 إلى 3 من 10 أشخاص فقط
يعرفون ماذا يريدون فعلاً
وما طموحهم المهنيّ في الحياة.
بصراحة، لقد فاجأتني هذه الأرقام قليلاً،
لأنها تُمثل كذلك نسبة الأشخاص
الذين يعملون باختصاصهم
خلال السنوات الـ 5 أو الـ 10
التي تلي التخرج.
أنا هنا اليوم لأتحدّث عن الطموح المهنيّ،
ولكنني بدلاً من أن أُلقي عليكم نصائح عامة
أو نتائج دراسات أو قصص نجاح أشخاص معروفين،
سأستثمر الـ 15 دقيقة التالية
في تسليط الضوء على
أهم المحطات المهنية في حياتي الخاصة،
والتي من الممكن أن تدفعكم للتفكير بحياتكم
أو بحياة من حولكم.
سأخبركم قليلاً عن نفسي:
تخرجت من الهندسة المعلوماتية
من جامعة دمشق،
وأتيت إلى أميركا لدراسة الماجستير في
إدارة الموارد البشرية وإدارة أعمال
في جامعة بوردو،
والآن أنا أدرس الدكتوراه
في قيادة وسلوك المؤسسات
واختصاص التعليم العالي
في جامعة سان فرانسيسكو في كاليفورنيا.
أعمل الآن مديراً للمجتمعات الرقمية
في جامعة ستانفورد
ومرشد مهني وأكاديمي
سأحكي لكم عن 5 تجارب.
التجربة الأولى:
اسأل السؤال الصحيح.
ماذا تريد أن تصبح عندما تكبر؟
من منّا لم يُسأل هذا السؤال "العبقري"
أكثر من 10 مرات في حياته.
كان هذا السؤال يحيّرني ويخيفني
منذ أن كنت صغيراً،
ليس لأنني لا أعرف ماذا أريد
ولكن لأنني كنت أريد
أن أفعل الكثير من الأشياء
كالكثير من الناس؛
طبيب وأستاذ وعالم رياضيات
وبطل خارق وفيلسوف له ذقن
وشيخ يسكن فوق الجبل
ومدير يتنكر لمراقبة موظفيه
وعازف بيانو.
أحببت أن أفعل الكثير من الأشياء
ولكنني أخاف من مشاركة هذا مع الكبار
كي لا يستهزأوا بي.
لذا كنت أكتفي بقول:
"أريد أن أصبح طبيباً"
لأن الكبار يشعرون بالرضا
عند سماعهم مثل هذه العبارة.
فأكثر ما يريح الكبار
أن يعرفوا أن طفلاً أو شاباً
يكبر وهو يعرف ما يريد،
حيث ينظرون له على أنه مميز
وله مستقبلٌ واعد.
طبعاً تزداد أهمية هذا السؤال وتواتره
كلما اقتربنا من الثالث الثانوي أكثر.
فمن المعروف أن الاهتمامات تتولد
من الكتب، القصص، المدرسة، العائلة والتلفاز
ولكن برأيي الشخصي،
أكثر من أثر باهتماماتي وشكّلها
هو تشجيع الأساتذة
أو عدم تشجيع بعض الأساتذة الآخرين.
الأساتذة الذين دفعوني لحبّ موادهم
هم الذين جعلوني أركّز على المادة
وليس الامتحان،
والذين كانوا يعززون حبّ المادة في داخلي.
برأيي، "ماذا أريد أن أصبح عندما أكبر؟"
هو سؤالٌ خاطئ،
لأنه أولاً يفترض أن الاهتمامات
لا تتغير مع الزمن،
وثانياً أنه لديك اهتمام واحد فقط،
وثالثاً والأهم، أنه لديك اهتمام متشكّل
وتعرف ما تريد في الحياة.
الأصح بدلاً من سؤال
كيف تريد أن تكون عندما تكبر؟
السؤال الصحيح:
"كيف تكبر وتمارس مجالاً معيناً؟"
هنالك فارق كبير.
فمثلاً، أنا مهتم بالحاسوب والإدارة
ولا أعرف بأيّ منهما أختصّ.
في هذه الحالة، سأعمل بجدّ وأحاول التعبير
عن حبّي لهذين الاختصاصين،
وأجرّب وأسأل وأبحث وأتدرّب
في هذين الاختصاصين
ثم أرى أيّ من الاختصاصين أحببت،
وأيّ منهما أكثر انسجاماً
مع مقدراتي وخبراتي
أكمل طريقي به.
الفكرة التي أود إيصالها
الاهتمام لا يأتي قبل العمل
والطموح المهني هو نتيجة اجتهاد ومثابرة
بموضوع ما
والعوائد من هذا التعب
هي التي تولد هذا الاهتمام.
التجربة الثانية: آمن بنفسك.
عملت في السنة الثانية بالجامعة
بشركة مزود إنترنت في سورية
قسم دعم تقني على الهاتف
من الساعة 12 ليلاً وحتى 8 صباحاً.
كنت أذهب بعدها إلى الجامعة،
وكان العمل متعباً والراتب قليل
ولا خبرة أحصدها منه تستحق كل هذا العناء.
كان كل من حولي ينتقدني
حول طبيعة عملي،
ولكنني لم أكن آبه بهم،
فقد كنت مؤمناً بنفسي.
فقد كان مدير العمل مؤمناً بتطوير ودعم
موظفيه عن طريق الدورات التدريبية.
وقد كان يوفّر دورات باللغة الإنكليزية
من قبل القنصلية البريطانية
لجميع موظفي الشركة الراغبين
بتطوير لغتهم الإنكليزية.
والطريقة الوحيدة التي كنت أستطيع
من خلالها التسجيل في هذه الدورات
هي جعل دوامي ليليّ،
لأنني كنت مشغولاً بالجامعة نهاراً.
نصحني الكثيرون بالعمل في الدوام المسائيّ
حتى يكون راتبي أفضل
إلا أنني كنت مؤمناً بأهمية
دورات اللغة الإنكليزية بالنسبة لي.
كانت لغتي الثانية بالأساس
هي اللغة الفرنسيّة،
إلا أنني كنت أرغب بتطوير لغتي الإنكليزية
لهذا سجلت في 10 دورات خلال سنتين
وبالفعل فقد تعلّمت الإنكليزية
وقد فتحت أمامي أُفقاً جديدة في المستقبل.
لو أنني لم أجرّب الدوام الليليّ
كما قال لي الكثيرون
لما كنت قد حصلت على فرص كبيرة
وتطوّرت مهاراتي إلى ما هي عليه الآن.
التجربة الثالثة: عيادات العمل.
كُن طموحاً.
ساعدني شخصٌ أثق به ويعمل في MTN
بالحصول على فرصة تدريب
في أحد الشركات الكبيرة التي كان يعمل بها.
كان العمل بسيطاً جداً
وكانت مدّة التدريب لمدة شهرين فقط.
فقد كان العمل عبارة عن تحديث
بيانات نظام الموارد البشرية
بناءً على السير الذاتية الموجودة
في النظام.
وبالتالي كان دوري قراءة 100 سيرة ذاتية
يوميّاً، وتحديث بيانات النظام.
وقد بدأت بالعمل أنا وصديقٍ لي
إلا أنه ترك العمل بعد أسبوع
قائلاً: لا أريد العمل بهذه الأمور
فقد كان يعتبر ألا خبرة فيها.
وقد كان محقّاً، فهذا العمل ليس له علاقة
باختصاصنا في الهندسة المعلوماتيّة.
أما بالنسبة لي، فقد أحسست بوجود فرصة،
إلا أنني لم أكن قادراً بعد على رؤيتها،
فقررت الاستمرار بهذا العمل.
وبالفعل، فقد كنت أحرز تقدّماً يوميّاً
بقراءة السير الذّاتية.
وقد أصبح لديّ القدرة على الحكم
على أي سيرة ذاتيّة خلال 10 ثوانٍ.
وأصبحت مرجعاً للسير الذاتية في الجامعة
دون أن أشعر بذلك.
فقد كنت أشارك مع زملائي ما أعرفه عن
السير الذاتية
وكيف يجب أن تكون شكلاً ومضموناً
فأصبحوا يطلبون منّي مراجعة سيرهم الذاتية،
ومساعدتهم على كتابتها عند تقدمهم لعملٍ ما.
وبالفعل، كنت أقوم بذلك.
وبالتدريج، أصبحت لا أساعد الأصدقاء فحسب،
وإنما أصدقائهم والأقارب
وأشخاصاً لا أعرفهم كذلك.
وبعد 5 سنوات، كنت قد كتبت أكثر من 1000
سيرة ذاتية في حياتي.
ومضت الأيام، وعملت في برنامج
الأمم المتحدة الإنمائي (UNDP)
بتطوير الخدمات الحكومية،
وخلال تلك الفترة سمعت عن
مشروعٍ ناشئٍ شبابيّ
يساعد الشباب على دخول سوق العمل.
فذهبت وحضرت من محاضراتهم،
تواصلت معهم أكثر وسألتهم عن عملهم،
وأصبحت أحضر ورشاتهم التدريبيّة،
وكذلك كنت أشارك بها.
ومع مرور الوقت،
شعرت أن عملهم هذا لم يكن مجرد اهتمام
بل كان هنالك أشخاصاً يعملون به كمهنة.
وفي أحد الأيام، كانت لديهم فرصة،
وكنت متحمساً جداً للعمل معهم بها.
وبالطبع، تلقيت نقداً من الكثيرين
لأنني تركت العمل مع الأمم المتحدة
من أجل العمل على مشروعٍ ناشئ.
إلا أنني لم ألقي لهم بالاً.
وفكّرت أنني إذا استطعت العمل
في مكانٍ مهم كالأمم المتحدة مرّة،
إذاً، يمكنني فعل ذلك مرة أخرى.
أما إيجاد عمل ضمن اختصاصي وأحبّه
فقد كانت فرصة لا تأتي دوماً.
وبالفعل، قمت بالتقديم للعمل مع
مشروع شباب،
وقمنا بتأسيس مشروع
عيادات العمل،
وقد أثّر هذا المشروع كثيراً على حياتي،
لأنّه أثّر على الشباب وأدى إلى
بناء قادةٍ أفخر بهم دوماً.
إذاً، لو سمعت ما قاله الناس،
ولم أعمل بهذا المشروع،
ما كنت لأسس المشروع
الذي أعتبره أحد أهم مشاريع حياتي،
وما كنت لأستطيع التأثير
في الكثير من الشباب.
ولأوّل مرةٍ في حياتي،
عرفت أن طموحي المهنيّ هو
أن أساعد الشباب في الحصول على فرص عمل.
وقد كنت أتصفّح مواقع جامعاتٍ عالمية
كجامعة ستانفورد،
وأقوم بتحميل موارد تدريبية،
وأتمنى لو أنني أعمل بهذه الجامعة.
وقد أثمرت هذه الجهود،
وتطوّر مشروع عيادات العمل
وأصبح مشروعاً مهمّاً.
التجربة الرابعة:
توقّع الضغوط.
هنالك 4 ضغوط نفسية
واجهتها بنفسي ولاحظت أن الكثيرين
قد واجهها كذلك
بحكم علاقتي مع الشباب بمختلف الجامعات
وقد وجدت أن هذه الضغوط النفسية
تتكرر في عدة دول وعدة أماكن.
الضغط النفسي الأول يدعى
متلازمة المحتال أو imposter syndrome
وهو شعورك أنك إنسان مزيّف،
وأنّك لا تستحق المكان الذي أنت فيه،
وأن حصولك على فرصة ما
هو مجرّد صدفة،
وأن الجميع سيكتشف أنك لا تستحق
هذه الفرصة عاجلاً أم آجلاً.
إن هذا الشعور منتشرٌ بكثرة،
وخاصة عند الأشخاص
ذوي التحصيل العلمي والمهني
بالأماكن التي يكون التنافس عليها شديداً.
الضغط الثاني: متلازمة البطة أو
duck syndrome
الاسم مضحك، ولكن المتلازمة ليست كذلك.
إذا نظرت إلى البطة وهي تعوم
ستجدها شديدة الهدوء والسكينة،
ولكن إن نظرت إليها عن قرب،
ستجد أن قدميها تتحركان بسرعة تحت الماء
وكأنها في سباق أولمبياد.
يشعر الشباب كثيراً بهذا الأمور.
فهم يحاولون إظهار الوجه اللامكترث
والهدوء لمن حولهم،
مع أنهم مضغوطون نفسياً من الداخل.
وبسبب إظهار مشاعر مخالفة لما بداخلهم،
يولّد ذلك لديهم ضغطاً نفسيّاً،
والذي بدوره يولّد اكتئاباً
ومشاكل نفسية أخطر.
الضغط الثالث: الفومو FOMO
وهي أن تشعر بالخوف من
إضاعة فرصةٍ ما.
"Fear of Missing Out"
وهذا النوع من الخوف منتشرٌ منذ زمن
إلّا أنه يزداد الآن، خاصّة مع جيل زي
أو جيل الألفية،
وهو أنّك تخاف عند ذهابك
إلى مكانٍ ما
من إضاعة فرصةٍ أخرى في مكانٍ آخر.
أو أن تحضر محاضرة وأنت غائب الذهن
لأنك تفكر في تعليقٍ
لم ترد عليه على الفيس بوك
وبالتالي فدماغك دوماً مشغولٌ بمكان آخر،
ولست موجوداً في اللحظة الآنية.
وهذا يولّد التشتت والقلق
والضغط النفسيّ.
الضغط الرابع والأخير:
والذي يدعى فوجي (FOJI)
"Fear of Joining In"
الخوف من الانضمام إلى
مجموعة أو حلقة ما.
وهو الخوف من تقييم الناس لك
عندما تبادر وتعبّر عن نفسك
في أي مكانٍ، سواءً كان
اجتماعياً أو دراسياً أو مهنياً.
وبالتالي تخاف من السؤال في المحاضرة
حتى لا يقول الطلاب أن سؤالك ليس صحيحاً،
أو من الإجابة حتى لا ينظر لك الناس
نظرة غريبة في حال كانت جوابك خاطئاً.
وقد تخاف أن تشارك في اجتماع عائليّ.
أو أنك تخاف من الكتابة أو التعبير.
هذا الخوف من التعبير يأتي أحياناً من
الخوف من الانضمام (FOJI)،
ويزداد كلما كانت البيئة مختلفة
عن البيئة التي نشأت فيها.
فلا تشعر بالراحة أبداً إذا سافرت
إلى بلد مختلف أو ثقافة مختلفة لوحدك،
وتحاول ألا يراك الناس.
رسالتي لك أن تتوقع أن تمر
بهذه الضغوط الأربعة
لأن الجميع يمرّ بها.
إذاً، أريدك ألا تعتقد أنها تحصل معك فقط،
لأنها تحصل مع جميع البشر بنسب متفاوتة،
وأحياناً، يمرّ جميع الأشخاص
بجميع هذه الضغوط معاً.
وكلّما كان الشخص ناجحاً،
شعر بهذه الضغوط أكثر.
إن كان كبيراً أو صغيراً،
شاباً أو فتاة.
والحل، أن تطرح على نفسك دوماً
الأسئلة العميقة التي تتيح لك اكتشاف
آفاق نفسك.
سأشارككم هذه القصة.
ألقى مدير شركة كبيرة محاضرة،
بآخر المحاضرة،
سأل الطلاب إذا كان لديهم أسئلة.
فقال له أحد الطلبة:
"لو عاد بك الزمن، ماذا تنصحنا أن نفعل؟"
فقال له: "يقول لك الجميع أنه عليك
أن تفهم الناس وشخصياتهم،
إلا أنني سأنصحك أن تكرّس فترة العشرينات
من حياتك في محاولة فهم نفسك،
فكلّما فهمت نفسك ومقدراتك
وعرفت من أنت وهويتك أكثر،
كلما ازدادت قدرتك على الإجابة على سؤال
لماذا أشعر بهذا الشعور
وكلما استطعت كسر النمطية
والقضاء على هذه المتلازمة."
التجربة التالية: كُن مبادراً.
قدمت إلى أميركا في عام 2010،
ودرست الماجستير عن طريق منحة fulbright
وكان اختصاصي موارد بشريّة،
وخلال فترة دراستي،
تواصلت مع المركز المهني في الجامعة.
بعد تخرجي، كان لديهم فرصة رائعة
لمرشدٍ مهنيّ للطلاب الدوليين.
تقدمت لهذه الفرصة ووصلت للمرحلة النهائية
بعد شهرين وتوقّعت أن يتم قبولي
إلّا أنني لم أحصل على القبول.
شعرت بالانزعاج كثيراً.
وذهبت للعمل بشركة أخرى،
والتي تم إغلاقها بعد 6 أشهر من عملي بها.
وفي رأس السنة، كنت جالساً فقررت إرسال
بطاقات معايدة للناس،
وقد كان من بين الأشخاص الذين أرسلت لهم
إحدى الأشخاص الذين قابلوني
عندما تقدمت للعمل بالمركز المهني للجامعة.
وتفاجأت بردّها بعد يومين حيث قالت:
إياد، إذا كنت مهتماً ولا تزال في المدينة،
لدينا فرصة جديدة ستُطرح بعد أسبوعين."
طبعاً، لم أكن أتوقع جوابها هذا
لأنني لم أكن أعلم أنه لديهم فرص بالأصل.
كنت أعايدها فقط
وبالفعل، تواصلت معها وأخبرتها أنني مهتم
ومن ثم حصلت على فرصة العمل.
وقد كانت مرحلة مهمة في حياتي.
عملت بالمركز المهنيّ،
وبعد ثلاث سنوات من بدأي بالعمل لوحدي،
كان لديّ فريق من 13 شخص،
وتم تصنيفنا كثاني أفضل مركز بأميركا.
وأرسلتني مديرتي إلى دورة تدريبية،
في ولاية Missouri
وتعرّفت على مديرة مركز آخر هناك.
لم يكن الانطباع الأول جيداً،
إلا أنني أحب أن أكون مبادراً في العلاقات،
ولا أحب أن أحكم على الانطباع الأول.
لذا، قمت بفتح حوارٍ معها،
وبعد 30 دقيقة قالت لي:
"أنت تذكرني بهذا الشخص."
فأخبرتها أنني معجب جداً به
وأنني أرغب بالتعرف عليه كثيراً.
فأخبرتني أنه صديقاً مقرباً.
وهو عميد التعليم المهني والعمل
في جامعة ستانفورد.
وقد قلت لها أنني سأكون سعيداً للغاية
إذا قمتي بربطي بهذا الشخص.
فقالت لي: "أبشر"
وبعد انتهاء الدورة التدريبية،
أرسلت لها تذكيراً بالأمر،
فقامت على الفور بوصلي به،
وتواصلت معه عبر السكايب،
وأخبرني أنه إذا كنت مهتماً
فلدينا منصب يمكنك التقديم عليه.
وبالفعل، قمت بالتقديم عليه
وبعد شهرين من التجارب،
لم أستطع الحصول عليه ولم يتم قبولي.
انزعجت ولكن ليس كثيراً،
لأنني متأقلم مع الرفض في حياتي،
ومعتاد على الوقوع والنهوض مجدداً.
فلم أكن أبحث عن عملٍ بالاًصل،
إلا أنني كنت أريد تضييق دائرة الراحة
الخاصة بي،
لأنني أصبحت مرتاحاً كثيراً في جامعة بوردو.
على كل حال، بعد ستة أشهر كنت
أتصفح موقعهم الالكتروني
ووجدت فرصة جديدة أفضل بكثير
من تلك الفرصة.
فقمت بالتقدم لهذه الفرصة
دون التواصل مع العميد الذي أعرفه،
ووصلت للمرحلة النهائية
في تموز 2015،
وفي كانون الثاني
أي بعد 6 أشهر،
كانون الثاني 2016
تلقيت اتصالاً منهم وأخبروني:
"مبارك لك إياد، لقد تم قبولك
لتشغل منصب مدير المجتمعات الرقمية في
جامعة ستانفورد"
شعرت بالسعادة كثيراً.
شعرت بإحساسٍ لم يراودني من قبل.
لأنني كنت في كانون الثاني 2006،
كما أخبرتكم،
أقوم بتحميل مصادر تدريبية للطلاب
من جامعة ستانفورد
وكنت أتمنى العمل بجامعة ستانفورد.
وفي كانون الثاني 2016،
أصبحت مدير المحتوى الرقمي
في هذا المركز الذي يعتبر حالياً
من أهم المراكز،
لأن المركز يركز على العمل من الهاتف
الخلاصة من هذه التجربة،
كُن مبادراً دوماً،
ولا تحكم على الأشخاص من حولك،
لأنه يمكن لأي شخص أن يكون إنساناً عظيماً
دون أن يكون ذلك ظاهراً عليك.
حسب تصورك لشكل الإنسان العظيم
كما أن أي شخص لديه محتوى،
لذا حاول أن تخرج المحتوى الجيد من الناس.
وإذا لم تنجح معك الأمور من المرة الاولى،
جرّب مرة أخرى، وحاول أن تضع نفسك دوماً
خارج دائرة الراحة.
بالنهاية، أحببت أن أشارك معكم
خلال الـ 15 دقيقة التي مضت
أكثر المحطات أهميّة في حياتي.
اسأل السؤال الصح، آمن بنفسك
اصقل اهتماماتك، توقّع الضغوط،
بادر بالعلاقات،
والأهم، استمر بالمحاولة.
فأنا سأستمر بالمحاولة.
أتمنى منكم مشاركة تجاربكم
على (#رح_ضل_عم_جرب).
وأتمنى منكم أن تستمروا بالمحاولة.
وشكراً.